more gold had been mined from the Mind
of Men
than the Earth itself
opportunity often comes disguised in the
form of Misfortune or temporary defeat
success is completely within your
control
listen to these quotes by Napoleon Hill
to become a successful human being today
if you don't believe in cooperation
look at what happens to a wagon that has
lost one wheel
weak desires bring weak results
just as a small amount of fire brings a
small amount of heat
the man who does more than he is paid
for
will soon be paid for more than he does
you are what you think
ask for advice from those who will tell
you the truth about you
even if it pains you to hear it
empty praise is not conducive to
development of self-improvement
[Music]
whatever the mind can conceive and
believe
it can achieve
every adversity every failure every
heartache carries with it the seed of an
equal or greater benefit
a quitter never wins
and a winner never quits
if you can't do great things
small things in a great way
when your desires are strong enough
you will appear to possess superhuman
powers to achieve
Mastery only comes with practice and
cannot come from just reading
instructions
do not underestimate imagination
everything great was first born inside
of the Mind
and only then created in our reality
wise men when in doubt whether to speak
or to keep quiet
give themselves the benefit of the doubt
and remain silent
the way of success is the way of
continuous pursuit of knowledge
people who don't have a lot of money
usually pick up other people's opinions
easily
the path to success is a path of
constant search for knowledge
set your mind on a definite goal and
observe how quickly the world stands
aside to let you pass
who told you that this is impossible and
who is he to so easily operate with the
word impossible in relation to your
ideas
we refuse to believe in what we do not
understand
you may be hurt if you love too much
but you will live in misery if you love
too little
our only limitations are those we set up
in our own minds
happiness is found in doing not merely
possessing
there are no obstacles to the mind
except those that we recognize
no man in all of history has achieved
anything great without first creating it
in his imagination
don't wait
the time will never be just right
when defeat comes accepted as a signal
that your plans are not sound
rebuild those plans and set sail once
more toward your coveted goal
a goal is a dream with a deadline
poverty is nothing more than the result
of our laziness or indifference
cherish your vision and your dreams as
they are the children of your soul
the blueprints of your ultimate
achievements
thought
subject to certain principles can be
turned into material values
dreams come true when desire becomes
action
ask for a lot from life and life will
give you a lot
there are no limitations to the Mind
except those that we acknowledge
if you do not conquer self
you will be conquered by self
it is not knowledge itself that is
valued
but how it can be used
neglecting to broaden their view has
kept some people doing one thing all
their lives
persistence is to the character of man
as carbon is to steal
any ideas plan or purpose may be placed
in the Mind through repetition of
thought
if you don't have money at 40 then you
will still have a chance to fix it
age does not reflect the ability to earn
big money
remember that it is not the lawyer who
knows the most law but the one who best
prepares his case who wins
if you must speak ill of another
do not speak it write it in the sand
near the water's edge
a person cannot achieve sustainable
success in life
until he realizes the true reason for
his mistakes
most great people have attained their
greatest success Just One Step Beyond
their greatest failure
most so-called failures our only
temporary defeats
fears are nothing more than a state of
mind
desire backed by faith Knows No Such
word as impossible
it is your responsibility to make sure
that positive emotions constitute the
dominating influence of your mind